for hours the fighting's been sporadic
but intense heart-stopping explosion
dripping the air shaking the ground a
military operation launched in the
Janine refugee camp just after midnight
they last saw an operation of this skill
carried out by Israel more than 20 years
ago during what became known as the
second interfada or uprising
this started with airstrikes in the
heart of a densely populated region
smoke could be seen rising from
residential buildings an operation
against what it described as terrorist
elements in the area claimed the Israeli
Army the Palestinian prime minister says
the assault is a new war against the
Palestinian people
what is happening is a new attempt to
remove the camp from existence and
displace its people the heroic Janine
and its stubborn and steadfast Camp are
resistant to the occupation and its
invasions just like the rest of our
cities Villages and camps our heroic
people will confront this aggression
that is taking place under the eyes of
the International Community where
innocent people are bombed by planes the
Israelis moved in with bulldozers and
armored vehicles as armed drones buzzed
overhead they pushed into the refugee
camp but met resistance from armed
Fighters and improvised explosive
devices Janine in the northern West Bank
is a stronghold for Palestinian armed
groups and the general area has been a
hotbed for attacks by Jewish settlers on
Palestinian communities and attacks on
Israelis Israel says this operation will
last as long as it takes
in recent months
genuine has become a safe haven for
terrorists from that safe haven
terrorists perpetrated Savage attacks
murdering Israeli civilians men women
and children as many children as they
could find
as I speak
our troops are battling the terrorists
with unyielding resolve and fortitude
while doing everything everything to
avoid civilian casualties
paramedics have reported major
difficulties in getting to those who've
been injured in the fighting even when
the Israelis give the UK for
Palestinians to enter Janine the roads
and buildings are so damaged it's
difficult to get help to those who need
it the Israelis carried out an operation
here last month that lasted 10 hours
this has already gone way beyond that
and there's no sign or sound that is
going to come to a conclusion anytime
soon Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Janine on
the occupied West Bank
Ibrahim has the latest from Ramallah
now as we are on the second day of the
Israeli assault on the Janine refugee
camp thousands of Palestinians say that
they've been forced to leave their homes
not many of them have places to go but
they were saying that it is becoming too
dangerous to stay when it comes to the
use of Israeli airstrikes when it comes
to the length of this operation that has
been so far the longest in years and
remember Palestinians in the Janine
refugee camp have been the center of so
many Israeli raids we're talking about
more than 100 Palestinians from Janine
who have been killed throughout this
year and last year so it is a tense
situation for them but many tell us that
this time it feels very very different
Palestinians across the occupied West
Bank have been trying to show support
for those fighters in Janine they say
that they will continue to do strikes
shops are going to be closed
Palestinians say that they do not feel
that they're safe under Israel's
military occupation they say that they
have the right to defend themselves
against the continued Israeli occupation
that has been spanning on for decades
including the illegal settlement
expansion the daily raids the killings
the checkpoints you name it there's a
lot of anger also directed towards the
Palestinian Authority yes the
Palestinian president has said it's he
is going to be stopping all contact with
the Israeli government and the security
coordination with them but Palestinians
say that they feel that the Palestinian
Authority is teethless is leaving them
alone fighting one of the biggest and
largest militaries in the world
the occupied West Bank
Israel is under growing International
pressure to stop the violence the U.N
humanitarian coordinator in Palestine
said she was alarmed by the scale of the
operation and called for the injured to
be given access to medical help
Jordan has called for an immediate end
to the Israeli operation and urged the
International Community to pressure
Israel's government
there's been condemnation from other
countries in the region Egypt said the
military operation was a violation of
international law Iran called it an act
of State terrorism it's also been
condemned by the Arab League
the U.N Secretary General spokesman
urged respect for international law
it is not acceptable for there to be
armed attacks in areas of high
population density and that's the case
uh all parties need to abide by
International humanitarian law we
certainly want all parties to avoid any
excessive use of force and that includes
uh calling on them to avoid any attacks
on hospitals such as what you've
mentioned and on uh on on civilian
infrastructure
Daniel Levy is a former negotiator for
the Israeli government he says Israel
might be carrying out a large-scale
assault to see if the International
Community will respond
this is part and parcel of the
structural violence of the occupation
and so what we see here I think is first
of all the continuity of the permanent
Israeli presence I think we see the
continuity of already a year plus and it
goes back to the previous Israeli
government and not the government today
that everyone
talks about its extremism and wears its
apartheid on its sleeve it doesn't just
do apartheid it shouts and screams about
it but it's the continuation of an
escalation the thing that's a bit
different here perhaps is I think this
government has been testing the water
to just make sure given how extreme
the world considers us to be will we
still have impunity from our allies will
the U.S still perhaps raise the
rhetorical bar a notch or two but do
nothing not hold Israel accountable will
our European allies will our allies in
the region those who have signed the
normalization Accords with Israel is
this going to pass without problems and
I think as they've escalated over the
last weeks what I think they have seen
is it's okay impunity is still there
that this just goes on and on and they
feel confident that they they could
undertake a mission of this level of
severity without cost or consequence to
Israel and its relations with the West
palestine's Health Minister Dr Mai
al-qaela says the humanitarian situation
in Janine is dire
less tuition in engineering is very very
uh difficult and very hard Israel
aggression against the Palestinians
engineering is made through many the
true destruction of many infrastructure
the water Network and the electricity
network is damaged especially inside the
refugee camp which make the life more
difficult for the refugees and the
health situation is really very critical
currently we have it it who were killed
by Israeli forces
and 80 injured the hospitals are crowded
with the injured and the health the
health staff some of them they cannot
arrive to the hospitals where they
should work and they should have their
assume their work the medical supplies
and the medicines were transported to
the uh to her hospitals that will be
enough for three months and this was
done last last week because we
anticipated that Israel is going to have
an aggression to the to Janine
governoret and
this morning we sent 108 units of blood
from the Central Blood Bank to Janine
because in last incursion there was a
shortage of blood blood in the blood
bank of the hospital
hundreds of Palestinians marched in the
Gaza Strip on Monday night to protest
Israel's offensive into the occupied
West Bank demonstrations took place
close to the Israel Gaza border to show
solidarity with those in the Janine
refugee camp Hamas which controls Gaza
says all options are open if Israel
continues the assault
has more from Gaza City
the Gaza has been blockaded for the last
17 years most of these Generations who
protested at the Eastern side they were
born and raised within this Israeli
blockade which means they are very
familiar with the patent that is
happening so far in which tension
happening in the West Bank and now
happening in gene where further is more
escalation all across Palestine enraging
a public response by Palestinians and
now we have seen several statements by
Hamas vowing a in a sense of response
gathered of course by the military a
joint room saying that if Israel
continues the violations of Palestinian
rights and the killing of Palestinian
civilians in Janine definitely they will
be joining in the following hours the
streets of Gaza are still filled with
life people are moving and continuing
with their life activities but it's all
Thoughts with the reality is that this
is the similar pattern that the previous
words held and it could be a potential
escalation in Gaza in the following
hours still we have to uh we have to
wait and figure this out